where there have been hundreds of
millions of dollars that have been
poured into the issue of homelessness
major efforts by private and public and
nonprofit sectors yet there's been an
increase of at least 33 percent in the
last five years of homelessness what has
failed what has not worked I don't think
the model failed in fact most people
look to Los Angeles and when I have
visitors other mayor's come here they
say we wish we had what you have the
funding the dollars the program the
construction it's just not enough four
years ago only nine thousand people were
being moved off our streets into housing
last year was more than 21,000 but we
still went up 12 percent so the number
is in 21,000 we have to get to 25 or
30,000 you're building affordable house
and what is affordable how much does a
person need to learn to be able to pay
the rent well in this county you have
about 30% of people paying half of their
income just to meet their rent and you
have about half of the people paying 30%
of their income to make the rent
that is the measure experts say puts
them on the verge potentially of
homelessness so when half of the
population could potentially be homeless
we have to build more housing that's
affordable to everybody in the last few
days we've been talking to several
families who are homeless these families
feel like they're being left behind like
they are not a priority because they are
a family unit no well this is a nation
that has effectively left behind
families that are homeless said it's
gonna be a lottery you're gonna have a 1
in 8 chance of getting assistance in
this city one in four chance in America
so three out of four American families
who need the assistance sorry it's up to
you dear fault good luck you keep
mentioning this is what when you do as a
country what do you need to do as a city
well we I think are the model we passed
one tax to build 10,000 units of new
housing no city's ever done that you say
that you are the model yet you have the
highest number of homeless people in the
country absolute they're not mutually
exclusive and I never claimed that
things are good out there I think people
have two fantasies one we can snap our
fingers and there's some way to get rid
of this overnight some huge shelter we
can put thousands of people into
someplace we could ship people
- or maybe for some that we could arrest
our way out of this or just clean the
streets out of the way that doesn't
solve homelessness on the other hand
this is a solvable problem here in Los
Angeles we've reduced veterans
homelessness by 80% since I've been
mayor and veterans I'm a veteran we're
no different than non-veterans it's just
the feds were there to help us